[Musique]
vous le savez je ne suis militant
d'aucun parti politique
dans quelques jours je serai confronté
comme vous à l'élection présidentielle
comme vous j'aime mon pays
et si j'ai décidé aujourd'hui de vous
dire deux ou trois choses sur raymond
barre c'est que j'ai observée depuis
quelques semaines le débat politique
j'y vois beaucoup de politiciens de
mauvais acteurs pour la plupart
j'entends beaucoup de promesses mais je
n'ai trouvé qu'un homme vrai qu'il ne
fait pas de concessions look qui ne
promet pas la semaine des quatre jeudis
ne tendent pas d'hypnotiser ce
compatriote cet homme c'est raymond
barre un homme vrai et j'en suis sûr un
homme d'état comme pouvait l'être le
général de gaulle je voyage beaucoup je
sais que l'avenir sera difficile pour
mon pays la chine le japon les états
unis et encore plus près l'allemagne et
l'italie sont devenus très fort pour
nous on a besoin d'un leader solide
énergique un homme comme raymond barre
qui est respecté et écouté partout à
l'étranger
on dit souvent de tel ou tel candidat
depuis quelques jours c'est un bon
candidat
il fait une jolie campagne mais ce qu'il
faut à notre pays je crois
ce n'est pas un champion de campagne
électorale c'est un président un grand
président voilà pourquoi je vous demande
d'écouter maintenant raymond barre
répondre aux questions de philippe
vasseur il va vous dire comment
concrètement ils comptent guérir la
maladie du chômage
simplifier notre fiscalité et baisser la
tva
écoutez le bien le 24 avril prochain
quand vous placerez votre bulletin dans
l'urne
je sais que vous penserez à l'avenir et
surtout à l'avenir des jeunes mais en
votant pour raymond barre une chose est
sûre vous penserez d'abord à l'avenir de
la france
philippe vasseur c'est à vous
sur lombard pour l'élection
présidentielle nous devons penser à
l'avenir et il ya une question
aujourd'hui que se posent les français
sur l'arni sur leur avenir
si nous ne devons en retenir qu'une
seule c'est celle là le chômage
certainement et en même temps que nous
pensions à l'avenir nous devons
considérer une mesure immédiate c'est
celle qui le fait prises en faveur des
fins de droits en faveur de toutes ces
personnes qui aujourd'hui ne dispose
plus les ressources nécessaires pour
survivre
j'ai en 1981 en février 1981 a créé
l'allocation de fin de droits il y en
avait 15 mille aujourd'hui il y en a 600
milles je crois qu'il faut prendre de
manière urgente des mesures tendant à
attribuer une aide personnalisée
décentralisée adaptable à chaque
situation à ce qu'ils ont à faire face
aux épreuves
né de la perte de leurs activités c'est
un engagement que je prends alors là
vous apporter une solution il médias
c'est le problème immédiat des cas
pathétique à des situations dramatiques
mais pour le reste pour la suite
il faut offrir la possibilité de trouver
des emplois de créer des emplois peu de
gens parlent aujourd'hui c'est un débat
qui est absent un débat de fond qui est
absent de notre campagne pourquoi ce
vide c'est vrai ou en temps les gens
dire les gouvernements de droite ont
échoué avant 80 après 80 et les
gouvernements de gauche ont échoué
aujourd'hui nous n'avons qu'à nous
satisfaire du traitement social du
chômage les petits boulots les tuques
les autres formules d'emplois précaires
nous allons vivoter comme cela je crois
que ne vont pas nous résigner
le chômage n'est pas une fatalité le
chômage et didier un seul nombre de
causes internationales et nationales
mais ce n'est pas une fatalité à
condition que l'on fasse la politique
qui convient oui mais ce bar vous avez
été comme on dit aux affaires vous avez
été premier ministre pendant cinq ans et
de votre temps il faut le reconnaître la
situation n'était quand même pas tout à
fait rose
je ne dis pas je ne dis pas le nombre
des demandeurs d'emploi a doublé de 1976
à 1981 mais j'avais à faire face à deux
chocs pétroliers
et vous savez que sous
gouvernement dont j'ai été le premier
ministre il y a toujours eu en france un
accroissement du nombre d'emplois créés
les demandeurs d'emploi augmenté parce
qu'il y avait deux cent vingt cinq 25
mille jeunes qui arrivaient à partir de
1977 tous les enjeux le marché du
travail
mais l'économie française continue à
créer des emplois
elle n'en crée pas suffisamment mais à
l'encré 146 1276 de 1976 à 1980 alors
que depuis 1981 la france a perdu des
emplois
il n'y a plus une création d'emplois et
à l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas de
création d'emplois en france
c'est ce point qui est le plus
préoccupant alors voyons ce qui se passe
à l'étranger ce que l'on crée des
emplois chez nos partenaires européens
un témoignage celui de bernard bosson
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
regardons autour de nous le nombre des
emplois en europe a retrouvé son niveau
le plus élevé depuis la guerre en cinq
ans l'allemagne l'angleterre l'italie
ont réussi à créer plus de deux millions
d'emplois
quelle différence avec notre pays la
comparaison permet de mesurer réellement
les conséquences des années mitterrand
comme ministre chargé des affaires
européennes
j'observe ce qui se fait ailleurs
partout il y as priorité à la formation
des hommes à l'investissement au
dialogue social
alors ya un contraste pourquoi ne fait
on pas en france ce qu'ont réussi
ailleurs en europe
eh bien on n'a pas fait les politiques
que ces serres et vous avez entendu le
ministre beauchamp qu'il vient insiste
sur une idée essentielle d'une part la
formation des hommes d'autre part la
compétitivité des entreprises dans la
formation des hommes d'abord et à
nouveau je vous propose d'écouter deux
témoignages le témoignage d'une jeune et
le témoignage d'un chef d'entreprise
secrétaire de direction
j'ai passé un bts bilingue je n'ai pas
mis longtemps pour trouver du travail
durant 10 minutes
cet effet le diplôme a été très très
important pour trouver du travail c'est
déterminant nous avons toujours les
mêmes problèmes
c'est un problème de manoeuvre nous
n'avons jamais trouvé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui de la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée non qualifiés je n'arrive pas
à comprendre en monoski à 3 millions de
chômeurs et jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas
réussi un seul ouvrier alors une jeune
qui trouvent du travail très facilement
un chef d'entreprise qui ne parvient pas
à recruter
la formation c'est une dérive du système
et on tire de ces deux interventions le
contenu de la politique à mener
il faut une grande politique de la
formation professionnelle liée à
l'éducation
qu'est ce que cela signifie en premier
lieu développer l'apprentissage 200000
apprentis en france un million
d'apprentis en allemagne fédérale
il faut doubler le nombre des apprentis
sur les cinq ans à venir 200 millions à
400 milles peut être 500 milles
apprentis c'est un effort à accomplir
deuxièmement il faut qu'il y ait une
cogestion du système de formation
professionnelle par l'état et par les
entreprises le rôle des entreprises est
décisif en la matière
troisièmement il faut des incitations
comme le crédit d'impôt formation ou les
par une formation de banias à permettre
aux entreprises et aux particuliers de
disposer des ressources nécessaires pour
la formation
voilà je crois les éléments de base
d'une politique de la formation
alors une fois que l'on a les jeunes
bien formés il faut qu'ils trouvent des
emplois et pour cela il faut qu'il y ait
des emplois dans les entreprises que
l'on créé des entreprises qu on les
développe qu'on les transmettent alors à
ce sujet vous avez réuni plus de 5000
chefs d'entreprise au mois de décembre
dernier c'était une grande opération
n'avait jamais fait ça je souhaite
aujourd'hui que nous puissions résumé ce
que pensent les chefs d'entreprises à
travers ces trois témoignages dans
l'innovation et les produits pour la
première fois de plus début de la crise
un outil de production entièrement
nouveau et révolutionnaire
si vous l'ignorez pas vous reculez et
pour vendre satisfait à des clients il
faut constamment sortir les produits
nouveaux aujourd'hui il faut créer les
emplois et seule l'entreprise est
capable de 13 emplois nous avons les
hommes
les chercheurs les créateurs mais nous
devons récupérer le marché intérieur et
extérieur et pour cela devenir
compétitif par rapport à nos voisins
allemands italiens et anglais
il faut une grande réforme fiscale un
soutien à l'investissement matériel
immatériel et surtout faisons confiance
aux chefs d'entreprises la création
d'entreprise
voilà le véritable traitement économique
du chômage
un emploi sur deux nouvellement créée
est le résultat de la création d'une
entreprise nouvelle et je crois que
aujourd'hui ceci correspond un profonde
aspiration des français de
transformation culturelle de notre pays
puisque plus de 5 millions de français
souhaitent créer leur entreprise et que
700 mille autres ont un projet précis de
création d'entreprise
à moins d'un an voilà pourquoi je crois
il faut vraiment mettre le paquet et oui
le paquet sur la création d'entreprise
alors mais ce bar on met le paquet sur
l'entreprise
oui vous avez évoqué ce colloque fait
c'est en discutant et les chefs
d'entreprise que je suis arrivé à
définir les grands axes d'une politique
pour l'entreprise d'abord la création
d'entreprise simplifier les formalités
et donner des avantages fiscaux à ceux
qui créent les entreprises exonération
de l'impôt sur les sociétés pendant cinq
ans deuxièmement il y à une aide
apportée aux entreprises existantes pour
qu'elles se développent alors qu'est ce
qui est indispensable
les charles d'abord il faut stabiliser
les charges et progressivement les
réduire voilà pourquoi je considère
qu'il faut réformer la taxe
professionnelle et je souhaiterais le
faire avant la fin 2009 188 plafonner la
taxe professionnelle à 3% de la valeur
ajoutée et modifier les mécanismes la
taxe professionnelle de manière à ne pas
pénaliser les entreprises qui embauchent
les entreprises qui investissent
voilà pour les charges ensuite il faut
inciter les entreprises à investir à
faire de la recherche à développer le
réseau de distribution à l'étranger
le triptyque ces formations
investissements recherche
innovation c'est comme cela que nous
pouvons donner à nos entreprises la
compétitivité et enfin il ya la
transmission des entreprises
nous chefs d'entreprise vieillissent il
faut que des jeunes puissent reprendre
des entreprises
or les droits de succession ou les
droits de transmission sont élevés il
faut donc aménager ses droits pour
permettre à nos jeunes de reprendre des
entreprises et pour cela il faut
apporter certaines modifications
juridiques fiscales et par exemple en
ligne directe pourquoi ne pas exonérés
de droits de succession
l'héritier qui reprend l'entreprise et
qu'ils gardent l'entreprise dans son
patrimoine fut autrement dit les impôts
aujourd'hui ça va pas remarqué c'est ce
que pensent les français
je vous propose de les écouter et
d'écouter des témoignages qui vont vous
montrer qu'en matière fiscale il ya à
faire la procureure de voisins notamment
d'amérique
parce qu'il y a une chance importante
tarification les bières taxes sont plus
faibles en belgique en france et la tva
et j'étais faible également ces deux
facteurs nous font déjà confiance ou la
fiscalité directe et indirecte
aujourd'hui en france est mal adaptée
c'est un frein important de motivation
pourquoi travailler plus pour gagner
moins et j'ai d'ailleurs envisagé de
partir à l'étranger et en particulier
aux états unis pour trouver là-bas une
possibilité professionnels et
salariale qui permet de mieux m'exprimer
pour toi l'artisanat la fiscalité est
lourde
en plus le coût de la tva les clients
acceptent avec difficulté de voir en bas
de leurs factures 18,6 pour cent en plus
on a l'impression que c'est tout le
système des impôts qu'il faudrait
changer en france est-ce que c'est
faisable c'est la raison pour laquelle
je ne parle pas de mesures ponctuelles
en matière de fiscalité
je crois que nous devons modifier
globalement notre fiscalité ça se fera
pas du jour au lendemain mais il faut
avoir une perspective et il faut s'y
tenir résolument qu'est ce que j'ai
proposé j'ai proposé premièrement que
nous harmonisions notre tva avec nos
partenaires étrangers
nos taux de tva sont trop élevés ils
sont trop nombreux et sont trop élevés
si nous diminuons la tva nous allons
donner du pouvoir d'achat aux revenus
notamment aux revenus modestes et nous
allons améliorer la situation de nos
entreprises
croyez vous que le gouvernement au mois
de décembre dernier quand il a diminué
la tva sur les entreprises a fait cela
uniquement que par inspiration céleste
sur les automobiles sur les automobiles
deuxièmement il faut en matière d'impôts
sur les sociétés mettre nos entreprises
en état de concurrence avec leurs
partenaires étrangers parce que les
entreprises étrangères voient baisser le
taux d'impôt sur les sociétés
les sociétés pourront ainsi innover
investir elles disposeront de plus de
ressources propres ailes sont des troncs
- et en troisième lieu il faut tenir
compte du taux de l'impôt sur le revenu
qui peut décourager ceux qui travaillent
ceux qui investissent ce qui épargne car
c'est cela qu'il faut encourager
il faut éviter la fuite de cerveaux
comme en grande bretagne sous le
gouvernement travailliste comme en suède
et 7 en modifiant la répartition de
l'impôt sur le revenu qui est concentré
aujourd'hui fut 15 % de français payent
65 % de l'impôt sur le revenu il faut
modifier cette répartition de l'impôt
sur le revenu et faire en sorte que
ceux qui travaillent qui est un vestige
qui entreprennent puisse bénéficier du
rendement de leurs activités on voit
bien le fil conducteur de votre
politique économique qui est une
politique pour l'emploi mais vous êtes
un homme qui ne fait pas beaucoup de
promesses en tout cas pas de promesse à
la légère quelquefois on vous le
reproche même d'ailleurs enfin vous ne
devrez pas la pilule aux français si
vous me permettez cette expression
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous demander de
promettre quelque chose si vous le
pouvez car on sait que quand vous
promettez vous tenez est-ce que vous
pouvez promettre que si vous êtes élu le
chômage diminuera en france coûte elle
je ne fais pas de promesses
je le prends des engagements j'ai
indiqué à ce nombre de mesures précises
j'ai regardé ce qui se fait à l'étranger
je crois que nous pouvons mettre en
oeuvre une politique qui va conduire à
la réduction du nombre des demandeurs
d'emploi et qui va permettre à
l'économie française de créer de nouveau
des emplois
voilà l'engagement simple et clair qu'au
japon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]